now Sudan's Army and the paramilitary
rapid support forces have agreed to his
seven-day humanitarian ceasefire
brokered by the U.S and Saudi Arabia it
comes into effect on Monday evening now
the two sides have been locked in a
power struggle for five weeks more than
one million people have been displaced
by the fighting and at least 700 killed
both sides have failed to honor previous
ceasefires hibber Morgan joins us now
live from omdaman
um Hippa you know I actually have the
40-page document in my hands now which
talks about this short-term ceasefire
and the humanitarian arrangements for
Sudan it's lengthy it's detailed but
what does it really mean practically for
those on the ground in Sudan looking for
some sort of respite
well practically if implemented it would
mean that humanitarian Aid would be able
to come to the more than 6 million
people here in the capital hartum who
will still remain trapped due to the
fighting and have not been able to leave
and also practically it would mean that
people in the western region of Darfur
where fighting has also been ongoing for
more than a week now and where hospitals
have been destroyed leaving people with
no medical assistance will be able to
get access to the needed assistance but
that's if the deal is actually
implemented On The Ground by the two
sides the residents here in hartum who
we spoke to when we asked to ask them
about the ceasefire they say that
they're going to only believe it when
they actually see it on the ground many
people have been cut off from power and
running water since the start of the
conflict because of armed groups
specifically the rapid support forces in
the northern part of the capital
Khartoum occupying these plants and so
they say that when they see these plants
reoperating once again and when they see
the resupply of water and power back in
their homes uh over the next seven days
that's when they know that this deal
will be implemented of course it's due
to start in the late hours of Monday
here in Khartoum and in other parts of
the country and already we can see
plumes of smoke rising from the northern
part of the country of the capital in
the city of bahri in the early hours of
this morning and that's because again
the deal doesn't come into effect until
48 hours after it signing but it also
states that both sides should refrain
from any military activity during the 48
hours and should use this time to notify
and alert their troops on the deal and
its terms and specific specific points
for them to be able to implement it on
the ground people here say that they've
seen the previous ceasefires they
they've seen how the two sides have
agreed before to uh to implement a
ceasefire for Aid to be able to come in
and for people to be able to leave their
areas where there is active fighting and
conflict ongoing to safer zones but then
they're not sure if this one would hold
especially
again since previous deals have been
made but this is the first one that is
actually being signed and with monitors
from both sides and the United States
and Saudi Arabia so they say if it
happens on the ground that's actually is
that's when they will believe that it is
actually reality and you've touched on
the second part of perhaps my question
that you have as many ceasefires as you
want as many pauses in the fighting as
possible but at the end of the day
humanitarian agencies need to find a way
of getting other needs and other
supplies into the country despite the
water and the electricity you talked
about and they need confidence in an
agreement that allows them to do their
job and also confidence the public to
look for help in the right places
hey bear can you still hear me it's
sahil Rahman in Doha
uh we seem to Lost Heather we'll try and
get back to her through the morning